so the most recent Dragon Ball super
Manga chapter changed a pretty big fan
complaint with superhero and uh yeah
let's say everyone is talking about this
see in the superhero movie Vegeta is
training by meditating and Goku makes
fun of him as though meditation is
worthless and silly and I don't think it
takes a rocket surgeon to figure out why
that would put fans into an uproar
excuse
but in the most recent Manga chapter
toyotaro changed this line to just
simply have Goku surprise the Vegeta of
all people is meditating toyotaro has
really changed almost nothing in his
adaptation of the movie and while that
has been pretty painfully boring for the
most part at the very least I can
appreciate that he went out of his way
to change this bit it just seems so
insanely silly in the original and as
children say rare toyotaro w